Mass land destruction has been a
contentious topic since the beginning of
the format and now is hotter than ever.
But today I'm here to contend that mass
land destruction isn't the answer, but
rather more like burning down the house
for a wasp nest. While it's
understandable, very understandable,
there are better alternatives which we
will go over if your play group is
troubled by the mass rem players. This
is Jyn with Next Level Commander. If
you're familiar with the format and are
looking to take it one step further,
this channel is perfect for you. So, the
hate for land stems from the social
implication of lands being untouchable,
which coincided with the rise of ramp
strategies. Big green decks hide behind
the 40 life barrier and the use of
politics to carry them through their
power vacuum in the early game and
overwhelms the table with inevitability
later on. And it seems they're not
taking their foot off the pedal in terms
of design either. Starting with Tayova
being an early slip perceived to be a
giant middle finger to the players
putting serious effort to craft
synergistic engines just to see the
civic player outvalue them with the most
brainless plays. And fast forward to
today, they dug the hole even deeper
with things like earthbending. Ah, the
lens returning after use is extremely
abusable, but they knew it and they
tried to limit the mechanic itself to
once a Yeah, never mind. Yeah. So, once
again, the pitchforks have risen. People
are dusting off their Armageddons and
ruin nations, and it's time for another
round of mass land destruction
discussion, MLDD for short. I've played
and played against my fair share of land
stacks, ramp decks, so yes, I know the
issue. Yes, these decks need to be
punished, but no, mass land destruction
is far from the only option and
definitely not the best one. The first
reason is the one that everyone uses and
because it's a solid argument, it can be
unfun. I mean, EDH is a long format
where ideally every deck gets to do
their thing and in the end a winner
emerges. But when you erase all lands
from the equation, there will be decks
being locked out for the remainder of
the game, which can be 20, 30 minutes or
more. Now, isn't it their fault for not
being equipped to deal with the
situation? Kind of. I mean, some decks
are just better at managing certain game
safes than others, but every deck has a
weakness. For example, my dragon deck
doesn't fold to getting his commander
stolen, but my Gitrock Ravenous Right
deck certainly does. Meanwhile, an
Armageddon or just a ruination will
destroy dragon, but Gitrock will
probably recover faster than anyone
else. Is one deck better built than the
other? Not necessarily. It's just kind
of random. The format is so wide, right?
And I can't deny the fact that some
players actually enjoy navigating around
limited resources, but oftentimes these
are the more experienced players. For
the new world players, what happens
after the nuke largely comes down to
random chances. See, this is the second
issue, randomness. The outcome of an
Armageddon is often down to luck. And
often times is not in favor of you, the
caster. The ones who come out really far
ahead from Armageddon are the decks that
lean heavily on artifact ramp, which
aren't playing the fairest game either,
and you just propel them to victory. The
next to recover from Armageddon is, as
it turns out, the ramp deck. Yeah, lens
deck are good at working with lens. Who
knew? Splendid reconation used to be a
one-off effect, but the past few years
saw half a dozen new entries. Now, don't
forget about stuff like life from the
Lone and Crucible of Worlds either. So,
there's a chance that the ram deck you
just quote unquote host comes back
mostly unscathed after a few turns while
everyone else remain in the ditch
staring at you angrily. The house is
gone forever, but the hornness might
still return. Plus, with the ubiquity of
protection spells nowadays, firing off a
mass land destruction probably has a 15
to 20% chance of straight up winning the
game for someone else. So, because of
these reasons, I don't think it's a good
idea to just toss Armageddons into
random decks as a silver bullet. But
what if you build your deck around blown
up lands? Well, that's problem number
three, is very difficult. I mean, the
most consistent and powerful ways to use
mass land destruction, like we said
earlier, pairing them with protection
spells or mana rocks on mass. But in
that case, your deck is probably just as
oppressive as the big ram decks and
arguably even less fun to play against.
But if you want to tone it down, it
becomes massively inconsistent. It's
also extremely difficult to find the
right timing to fire off a mass land
destruction spell. So, I'd say you need
to be fairly experienced at the game,
knowing when to find that window.
Otherwise, people might just think
you're griefing. So, you see the
problem. It's either oppressive or
extremely inconsistent. A newer player
won't be able to use this nuclear weapon
effectively. And more experienced
players should have better ways to deal
with rep. They do. Yes, that's what
we're going over here. The alternative
ways to host big dumb ramp decks without
having to turn EDH into a dice game in
prison. Well, let's be a little more
creative here. Every strategy has a
weakness. Unfortunately, EDH is not a
balanced game in any way. But
fortunately, it is balanced in that
every deck has to choose between
consistency and all-roundedness. If a
ramp deck wants to ramp consistently,
it's going to struggle with gas. You
know, top decking more ramp spells when
you don't want to. How do you fix that?
while you play blue. But then the deck
is filled with blue and green spells and
will struggle with early pressure. There
are very few exceptions to this. We
attack them where they're weak instead
of simply dealing with the symptoms. The
most straightforward way is aggro. In a
format with a healthy dose of aggro,
ramp decks will be in check. I promise.
Ramp is only problematic when everyone
is trying to value your Boros eggs
decks, your Ratos big mana decks, mono
white control. Yeah, you're not going to
outvalue Simic. So aggro, you don't have
to straight up kill them, but setting
them to a healthy 15 life will make the
late game much more manageable. Aside
from aggro, a solid control deck with
answers can also pick the ram decks
apart if you play it right. Like
mentioned earlier, these greedy decks
always have a certain imbalance with
lower than average card quality tied
together with massive draw spells. Well,
let's counter these draw spells, for
example. As long as we choke them where
it really matters, there's a decent
chance they will just topple over. And
finally, threat assessment. Sure, we can
let the RAM deck do its thing once,
twice, or even thrice, but you can
consider this to be the calibration
period, but once we're beyond that,
there's no reason for your table to buy
into the I have no threats nonsense. No,
a turn six straggler drama is not scary.
The dude with 12 lens and a full grip is
and should always be the number one
target. And finally, if you really
really want to blow up lens, and
secretly we all know it's it's not even
for the green player anymore. You just
enjoy the fire, there are a few pieces
I'd like to recommend. Starting with
what I believe to be the number one land
destruction spell. Not close.
Catastrophe. Plating 7,000 decks only
while Armageddon is in 30,000. This is
criminal. Catastrophe is perfect because
80% of the time it's a board wipe. an
overcosted one admittedly, but a wipe is
a wipe. God knows how many times I've
been saved by a late game undo
inversion. And the other 20% of the
time, we have the nuclear option when
you'll have the perfect board to win
with land destruction or someone really
has gone beyond your reach. This feels
like a perfect card for any aggressive
deck that deploys early. one because you
likely won't need a ward wipe on turn
four anyways, but more importantly, you
frequently put yourself in situations
where blown up lands can actually win
you the game with a very reasonable
chance of success. The drop off after
catastrophe is massive in my opinion,
but Kelan fire bombers can be a decent
choice. Dropping the land count down to
three is actually much friendlier than
zero. People can still do some stuff,
especially if they have a rock or two,
and if your deck has a lowish mana
curve, you can recover relatively
smoothly. This shuts off the advantage
of ramp decks at least for a few turns
without completely ruin everyone else's
game plan. Also being a creature cen
fire bombers can be blinked or copied to
keep the grip tight. And finally in a
similar but much friendlier vein
disciple of kais nin. This card is a
mass land destruction simulator in that
none of the lens are actually gone.
Nobody is salty. We all know it's
pretend but we get the prison boxing
experience. It will slow down the big
mana decks for at least a few turns
before they're back online again, which
buys valuable time for rest of the
table. Also, it hostes Tefar's
protection, which is sweet when it
happens. So, to sum things up, if you're
looking to do land destruction, my
advice would be no, unless you're a very
experienced player with a tight group,
and in that case, you don't really need
my advice. So, yeah, this is all I have
to say about MLDD. I am subjective and
not as not as articulate as I like to
be. So, please let me know your thoughts
in the comments. Do you have an MLDD
deck that works and is it enjoyable for
everyone? How did you manage that? This
is Jyn with Next Level Commander. If
you're looking for more discussions like
this, please subscribe for more and I'll
see